uh-uh-uh-uh
-v
[hudba]
[smích]
Dobrý den
vzduch na poplach
jsou zde uloženi jejich pacienti
lůžka v každé sekci mají cedule
své vlastní tam, kde jsou umístěny
[hudba]
24. jsem měl službu v 5 hodin
ráno jsem slyšel asi 12 pak třetí
na tři otoky byli lékaři všichni na místě
ale s úplně jiným pohledem na jednu
jeden
Nechtělo se mi věřit tomu alarmujícímu kufru
předchozí nestihla, bylo jí pouhých 25 let
číslo, když se rozhodla zůstat v práci
abych se nikam neevakuoval, pak už jsem
Posbíral jsem, co se dalo a hned jsem odešel
do práce a pak přijel
[hudba]
byli právě v budově No, ne
Air alarm dokázal zareagovat
někteří Máme všechno padlo a já žiju
nasadili si klobouky a otřásli se
a zhroutil se z výbušné vlny stylu
všichni se sklonili přes pracovní stůl k zemi
kovové konstrukce
nyní se pokusili obnovit vidět dříve
v tak skoro maximálně dobrém stavu
[hudba]
většina zaměstnanců je uvnitř
nemocnice od samého počátku málokdy někdo
odešel a žijeme zde, poskytujeme pomoc
odpočívejte pravidelně v plném rytmu
pracovní den
zajistit koordinaci, pokud máme
podávání některých léků
se více sjednotil
jedna velká rodina
kromě toho, že kolem slyšíme výbuchy
v koeficientech také vidíme, že v zemi a
kde je válka a
mnoho postižených dětí jsou civilisté
není to tam, je to tady
děti už kreslily své sny a všechny děti
hodně zoufalé bolesti, protože loučení
rodina s rodiči z
prarodiče Někde něco vědí
tam je jejich dům a tento obrázek, když víte, že to jde
je to člověk vykořeněný z domova
Ano ano
zoufalství těch dětí, které cítí
Obecně chápou, co tato válka je
bolest a jsou velmi znepokojeni a dokonce
malé děti ve 4 letech se ptají jestli
kdybyste byli čarodějem, kým byste chtěli být?
být
že chceš být, říkají poprvé
Chceme, aby tomu tak nebylo
děti, vyprávějí o ostřelování
ztráta bratrů a sester Ale všechno je stejné
Pokračují ve hře roztržitě
ale děti kreslí, skládají, baví se
pak si znovu pamatují ty situace a
je těžké to sledovat
[hudba]
ve Viberu se začalo uplatňovat více a
naši pacienti a
kolegové, dáváme čísla, protože my
podporujeme online konzultace
určitě někdo, kdo k nám nemůže
dosáhnout
jsou lékaři, kteří jsou ve válečné zóně
přední linie, kterou konzultují ve Viber yak
s těmi je lepší léky nepředepisovat
uvádí, že vidí v
armáda, které chtějí pomoci i
Napsal jsem jim seznam léků, pokud ano
najdete seznam analogů, ve kterých
příznaky, které jsou tam lepší s těmi hlavními
bolesti s jehlami planární překrvení
uši se subtimatickým třepáním hlavy
mozek
[hudba]
každé ráno je vidět kolegy štěstí a
první a druhý, když jdete ven
viz Jasno slunečno velmi cítit v
kolektivní podpora je pozitivní
a navzájem s takovou podporou
vždy podporujeme pacienty
moje odolnost vůči stresu
jsem připraven pokračovat v práci
No, já to necítím
nějaká panika nebo nějaké důvody
evakuace
Pořád chci tyhle akce
skončil a viděl méně bolesti v očích
děti
[hudba]
vše důležité její postavení každý je důležitý
lékaři, vojenští potravinoví dobrovolníci
zajištění učitelů, kteří pokračují
péče o děti je důležitá pro každého
přibližuje naši výhodu
[hudba]
po vítězství Ukrajina určitě bude
květina je nezávislá a svobodná Ještě víc
budeme
Jsem teď jednotnější
[hudba]